in this episode of the roadside MBA
we're heading out for the stagecoach
trails guest ranch in northwestern
Arizona to discover the real West whoa
rodeo
live the cowboy life I'm getting there
I'm gonna see what it takes to make a
living down on the rain wow this is so
pretty out here
rodeo you're doing great out here
doesn't matter where you're coming from
it's a long way to the stagecoach trails
guest ranch if you're coming from
California like us you'll probably end
up driving through the Mojave Desert on
interstate 40 across the state line into
Arizona then just before you hit the
small town of yucca you'll turn off the
highway onto the bumpy dirt road and
keep on driving for about 18 more miles
he drove is a long ways in an RV on dirt
roads and I don't know how we found it
but here it is the remote ranch is the
perfect place to forget your past and
get lost in a western cowboy fantasy
how many horses are here altogether 47
47 yeah here there is no civilization in
any direction as far as we can see we
are plumped down in the middle of a hot
dry desert and it's beautiful the vistas
go for miles their mountains off in the
distance sagebrush so if you want to be
in the American West on a horse this is
a good place to go
we're gonna find out why this business
works and why people will skip the beach
and travel thousands of miles to this
dusty spot to rope and ride in the Hot
Desert Sun paddy folks london cowboys
many of the guests come from as far away
as New York panavia first rule of a
cowboy put your head on the right way so
they showed us how to throw a rope and
do some cowboy stuff if you're not from
the US that's interesting to do don't
cover stuff I've never done this before
anima dreams yeah first time ever on a
horse sitting here never santa hopes
before we do only Western riding here so
it's a lot more relaxed this was Carrie
rynders childhood dream a Western horse
ranch she thought up out of books
as a kid it was a pull so strong she
eventually quit a comfortable life as a
travel agent to give it a go you guys
built this whole thing is that correct
correct so this was just empty desert
that is correct so you move out here you
start putting up buildings then you have
to get some customers what did you do
well that's saying if you build it they
will come
doesn't always work when you build in
the middle of the desert so I wanted to
talk to the guests to ask them how they
got here because it's not easy to get
here and I mean that not only the
physical process of getting here but
also the process of finding this
particular ranch among all the different
kinds of vacations that people can take
turns out the main place guests go to
find out if a dude ranch vacation is the
kind of experience that they might enjoy
is the internet sites like TripAdvisor
where previous guests post candid
reviews we went on that too TripAdvisor
and you know normally when you go on a
trip advisor you might get three or four
good reviews and then you'll get one
really bad stinky review but every
single review was was good every single
one that you could have just carried on
and online the ratings these days is
just you know you just compare with
people who are experienced already and
it's always a gives you a good idea of
what you're looking for TripAdvisor in
my opinion is probably one of the most
important marketing tools that we have
because I am told time and time again it
doesn't matter where are you coming from
if it's the United States Europe Asia
everybody's checking TripAdvisor to see
what people are saying about your place
I do it myself
and here's where an important economic
principle comes into play the ranch here
is an example of what we an economists
would call an experience good this is a
really important idea and concept of
business and so an experience good it's
a good the have to experience before you
can assess the quality we are 15 miles
from the interstate it's all dirt roads
right it's very difficult for people to
get a sense for what their experience is
going to be like here with experienced
goods customers rely on information
provided by others so it's important to
identify who the most influential others
are before internet sites like
TripAdvisor became Perry's biggest
source of recommendations she used to
invite tour operators to stay at her
ranch and experience themselves so
they'd be more likely to recommend it to
their clients you're gonna talk a lot
more about a place you've been to rather
than place you haven't and you're gonna
be much more convincing to the person
that wants to come here if you have
personal knowledge of it we have a term
for that in economics as well we'll call
those the intermediaries and their
intermediaries because they are the ones
that are kind of between the ranch and
the customers and so it's really
important for Kerry not only to market
to individuals but also to make these
tour operators really well informed and
so they understand what it's like to be
here so then they'll turn around and
recommend that to the customers that
they're making their choice for nowadays
the most critical intermediaries are
past guests who post reviews online when
they come to us and tell us what a
wonderful time they've had we'll say hey
here's a car would you mind if you get a
chance so that other people that maybe
haven't ridden before and are a little
leery about coming to a ranch will read
your review and say ok you know they've
done it they took very care of them
let's try it ourselves so managing their
reputation on the internet is critical
both in terms of making sure people have
a good experience and say good things
about them on TripAdvisor but also being
responsive if somebody has a bad
experience they have to get on
TripAdvisor and try to address that
a few bad reviews can be disastrous so
Kerry needs to do everything she can
while the guests are here to ensure they
have a great visit but making sure the
accommodations are clean and tidy the
matching guests - horses that suit their
experience level I know I'm never gonna
please a hundred percent of the people
100 percent of the time but we try
awfully hard to do it time to test this
experience good for ourselves how would
three economists measure up as modern
Cowboys would we love it or leave it
and would we recommend it to others for
me the horseback riding experience was
definitely getting out of my comfort
zone I've never done anything like this
before
I would say about 95 percent of all the
guests that come here is beginner riders
so she gave me the easy as horse Mike is
not a horse person Mike is a lot of
things but Mike is not a horse person
you're ready to get this experience
going let's do it
alright Mike was first amount just as I
showed you put your left foot in and
climb right up on and over and I've got
you there you go perfect I can't find
the seat belt yeah tell the truth we
were all pretty rusty in the saddle I
think the last time I was on a horse it
may have been 1980 so Carter
Administration potentially you think you
can reach that no problem I hardly ever
ride horses but I can remember that it's
a little tense at first that's a big
animal those things were 1,200 pounds I
think they said that's a big animal and
you're up pretty high hold it oh whoa
they could tell that I was the expert
ready to take on the skittish horse
whoa rodeo I am not really
I was kidding I'm not very good for yeah
then we were off and it was a truly
perfect experience good moment wow this
is so pretty out here that's great
I remembered the lessons that my mother
taught me and I sat up straight and I
think I looked good in the saddle
okay Scott did check his phone at least
once but for the most part we were just
three Cowboys on a trail in the American
West and even Mike seemed to momentarily
forget his fear of large animals I'm
getting there you're sounding more
relaxed too with my breathing heavily
before I know you were sweating
profusely I really tried while I was
writing not to focus so much on the
horse and saying on the horse as much as
looking out around me and when I was
able to do that it was very enjoyable
Mike's final challenge was the dismount
so you're just gonna take your right leg
up and over keep that foot in until you
get okay
Mike's dismount was not Olympic great if
Mike were a gymnast it would have been a
five point two five point three if Mike
were on Dancing with the Stars
he'd have been voted off unfortunately
so we're not destined to be cowboys but
that our time in the saddle teaches
anything the big lesson Carrie's
experienced good business works because
she understands how to reach customers
the first time and then keep them coming
back
so reputation reputation reputation that
is the key to her success she said about
half of her businesses repeat business
so that is just an incredibly profitable
niche if you just get people coming back
again and again once somebody gets in
the saddle we always adjust their
stirrups but it turns out after 14 and a
half years on the range Kerry's decided
to sell the ranch and
back to her home state of Wisconsin so
she can be closer to her children and
grandchildren and the reason she's being
able to sell it is because she's turned
a dusty collection of ranch buildings in
the middle of the desert into a valuable
asset using intermediaries to promote
her experience good business so the next
owner will be able to build on carries
success instead of having to start from
scratch that's rad oh that's I don't
know what you say lingo you guys say
Happy Trails or something can't say it's
a con yes a Happy Trails
so that's it from the roadside MBA team
Happy Trails vaya con Dios and bon
voyage
we've learned a lot on our travels from
Silicon Valley all the way out here to
Arizona now it's on to Sin City Las
Vegas Nevada where we say our goodbyes
until it's time for our next road trip